This is a lecture of how IBM
built a computer that plays
the very popular
game of Jeopardy!.
In 2004, IBM Vice President
Charles Lickel and coworkers
were having dinner
at a restaurant.
All of a sudden, the
restaurant fell silent.
Everyone was watching
the game Jeopardy!
on the television.
A contestant, Ken Jennings,
was setting the record
for the longest winning
streak of all time, 75 days.
Why was everyone so interested?
Jeopardy!
is a quiz show that asks complex
and clever questions like puns,
obscure facts, and
uncommon words.
It originally aired in 1964.
It covers a huge
variety of topics,
and it's generally viewed
as an impressive feat
to do well in this game.
No computer system has ever been
developed that could even come
close to competing with
humans on Jeopardy!.
IBM Research strives to
push the limits of science.
It has a tradition of addressing
inspiring and difficult
challenges over the years.
In the mid '90s, it built
Deep Blue, a computer,
to compete against the
best human chess players,
and then in the
mid '90s, Deep Blue
beat Garry Kasparov,
who was at that time
the world champion in chess.
Later it built Blue
Gene, a computer
to map the human genome.
In 2005, a team at
IBM Research started
creating a computer that
would compete at Jeopardy!
Of course, no one knew at
the time how to beat humans
or if it was even possible.
Six years later, a
two-game exhibition match
aired on television.
The winner would receive
a million dollars.
The contestants were Ken
Jennings, the longest winning
champion, whose longest
winning streak was 75 days;
Brad Rutter, who was the
biggest money winner of over 3.5
million; and Watson, a
supercomputer with 3,000
processors and a database of 200
million pages of information.
This is Jeopardy!--
The IBM Challenge.
And now, here is the host
of Jeopardy!, Alex Trebek.
Thank you, Johnny Gilbert.
Thank you, ladies and gentlemen.
And welcome, everyone, to a
very special Jeopardy! event.
For the next three
days, we're going
to be coming to you from this
IBM Research facility just
outside of New York City.
And let me tell you why.
A little over three years
ago, the folks at IBM
came to us with a proposal
that they considered
to be the next grand
challenge in computing.
And that was designing
a computer system
that could understand
the complexities
of natural language
well enough to compete
against Jeopardy!'s
best players.
Well, they think
they've succeeded,
and that's why we're here today.
So you are about to witness
what may prove to be an historic
competition -- an exhibition
match pitting an IBM computer
system against the two most
celebrated and successful
players in Jeopardy! history.
Sounds like a lot
of fun, doesn't it?
Developed and programmed
especially for this moment,
making its first appearance
on our national television
program, ladies and
gentlemen, this is Watson.
Just as I expected, that
was a very warm reception.
And I'm sure Watson
would've appreciated
the applause, except
for one thing.
Watson can neither hear nor see.
It will be receiving all of
its information electronically.
And as a matter of fact, what
you're looking at right now
is not the real Watson.
This is an avatar.
This is a representation
of Watson.
Watson, of course, is a
sophisticated computer system
too big and too heavy to
fit behind that lectern
on our stage.
But it is close by.
It's right next door.
And a little while
ago, I paid it a visit.
The very first thing
you will notice
as I come into Watson's
space is noise.
There is a lot of noise.
A little bit comes from Watson
himself, but most of the noise
comes from two very
large refrigerator
units that help to
keep Watson cool.
Now as you can see, Watson
has been set up in two units.
Each half contains
five separate racks.
Each of these racks contains
10 IBM Power 750 servers.
Now when you link
all of these servers
together, as they
have done for Watson,
you create a deep
analytic system
that is the equivalent of
2,800 powerful computers tied
together in a super
high speed network.